sea gtx igual a menos 4 x + 7 ok
entonces esta va a ser nuestra función y
nos preguntan cuál es el valor del
límite cuando x tiende a menos 1 deje de
x menos g evaluada en menos 1 todo eso
dividido entre x + 1 así que vamos a ver
primero cuál es el dibujo de esta
función g
voy a graficar primero los ejes que va a
ser un mejor esfuerzo en eso ahí está el
primero de los ejes tengo oops tengo
ahora el eje vertical un poco chueco
pero no pasa nada entonces este va a ser
el eje x este va a ser el eje ye y me
piden calcular el valor de este límite
sin embargo la gráfica de la función voy
a voy a pintarla aquí es esencialmente
una línea cuya ordenada al origen es 7
es decir intersecta el eje y en 7 y
tiene pendiente de menos 4 entonces es
bastante pronunciada bastante
pronunciada y digamos que la línea cae
la línea acá
muy bien entonces vamos a terminar
algunos detallitos por ejemplo sabemos
que por ser una línea la pendiente
justamente es menos 4 verdad justo esta
de la forma de igual a mx + b donde m es
la pendiente entonces la pendiente la
pendiente es igual a menos 4
esta es la gráfica es decir esto es
igual a gd x muy bien que es una línea y
ahora voy a pintar los puntos que me
interesan de hecho por aquí va a andar
el menos uno y pues a menos uno le
corresponde este punto de acá arriba
éste tiene coordenadas menos 1,7 menos 1
ok y si ahora me tomo un punto
arbitrario digamos que por aquí ande
nuestro punto x este punto de aquí tiene
coordenadas x coma gx ok entonces este
cociente que me están pidiendo aquí no
es otra cosa más que la pendiente verdad
qué
la pendiente entre estos dos puntos
porque si tengo gtx menos g de menos 1
estamos pensando en
esto de aquí gx menos g de menos 1
entonces va más o menos así en este
sentido para abajo i
también tenemos que de x de menos 1 y
abajo tenemos x1 que no es otra cosa más
que x menos -1 entonces estamos pensando
en esta distancia muy bien entonces si
yo quiero calcular la pendiente entre
estos dos puntos simplemente tengo que
calcular gx verdad está menos menos la g
evaluada en menos uno que sería esta y
todo eso dividirlo entre x
- y en este caso sería menos uno muy
bien entonces esta es la pendiente y que
si nos damos cuenta bueno en realidad
esto lo puedo quitar y es menos menos
nos da más
y entonces aquí en realidad lo puedo
dejar como un más y esto es exactamente
esta expresión que tenemos aquí entonces
está pendiente de entrada ya sabemos que
es que es menos 4 porque entre cualquier
par de puntos dentro de una línea la
pendiente siempre la misma entonces la
respuesta va a ser vamos a ponerlo con
otro color
oops quite esto
este era un más entonces la pendiente en
realidad es constante y es menos 4
verdad esto es igual a menos 4 y como
esto es constante pues no importa que le
metamos el límite verdad límite cuando x
se aproxima se aproxima a menos 1 ahora
bien esto podríamos hacerlo de forma
algebraica ya sabemos que en realidad la
pendiente no depende de la x la
pendiente es constante pero vamos a
hacerlo algebraica mente vamos a
calcular el límite cuando x tiende a
menos uno de gdx que en este caso será
menos 4 x + 7 y vamos a restar g
evaluado en menos 1 entonces sustituimos
aquí menos 1 sustituimos menos 1 y
tenemos menos 1 x menos 4 son 4 y luego
sumamos 7 entonces vamos a restar 11 muy
bien y ahora dividimos entre x más 1 muy
bien dividimos entre x + 1 y ahora
notamos que 7 menos 11 s
-4 muy bien así que este límite
simplemente se convierte en calcular el
límite cuando x tiende a menos uno de
menos 4 x menos 4 muy bien entonces
tengo menos 4 que multiplica a x + 1 y
luego dividido entre x más 1 y si x no
es menos 1 y no lo es porque nos estamos
aproximando como x no es menos 1 esto
este cociente está bien definido y puedo
cancelar así que esto es menos 4 y
entonces esto ya lo hicimos algebraica
mente pero en realidad estábamos
hablando de una línea así que la
pendiente entre cualquier punto sobre la
línea y es bueno de hecho la pendiente
entre cualesquiera dos puntos siempre es
la misma en este 4 en este caso es menos
4 pero nos fijamos en este punto
particular que era el menos 1,11